novell rock es un cristiano originario
de bagdad en 2014 viajó al exterior por
razones de salud
cuando regresó un año más tarde su casa
estaba ocupada por hombres armados
cuando regrese me di cuenta de que mi
casa había sido vendida y re vendida
varias veces trate de contactar a las
autoridades incluso de alto rango pero
nada todo fue en vano los delincuentes
con un acta de venta falsificada le
exigieron 150.000 dólares para
devolverle su casa
a níger al cole
durante esa época hice la denuncia en
varias comisarías de policía en las
oficinas de seguridad de la universidad
donde trabajaba en bagdad aquí están las
copias de todas esas demandas contra ese
grupo firmó a mí sí
dieter otro autor este profesor logró
expulsar a estos falsos propietarios de
su casa tras seis años de batalla
judicial es uno de los pocos casos de
este tipo con un final feliz en bagdad
sofiane hosein ali defiende a los
cristianos exiliados y expropiados de
sus bienes él colabora con la asociación
de derechos humanos hammurabi que por
años ha denunciado dichas expropiaciones
según él esos casos además de complejos
también pueden ser peligrosos
la situación de estos casos que atañen a
los bienes de los cristianos es delicada
los delincuentes ocupan sus casas y
dicen o pretenden estar bien
relacionados a veces solo es para
intimidar a los cristianos pero las
amenazas existen y por eso el miedo
también la directora de esta
organización dice que las expropiaciones
afectan en particular a las minorías y
pone en evidencia la ausencia del estado
de derecho en irak
y los cristianos están armados no tienen
clanes que lo respalden y no tienen
partidos políticos que se sacrifiquen
por ellos entonces es más fácil
así en uno de los países más corruptos
del mundo muchos cristianos no llevan su
caso ante la justicia aseguran que será
en vano y que miembros del gobierno
están detrás de estas expropiaciones el
gobierno iraquí contactado por france 24
refutó las acusaciones y pidió a las
víctimas dirigirse a las instituciones
competentes